[Music]  [Music]  [Music]  hi my name is Marisa and I developed  this recipe and I have some tips for you  guys  for this recipe we use gel food coloring  they're a little more pure and stable  when we use liquids we didn't have as  good of results we use coconut oil for  this recipe because it's clear in color  and also has a higher smoke point if you  don't have it you can always use canola  oil a great way to know if your pan is  hot enough is to put two kernels of corn  in to cover the pan and watch till they  pop then you can add the rest of the  kernels and the sugar we chose to do  rainbow colors for our popcorn but you  can do any combination you like you can  do your favorite sports team different  holidays or a baby shower your choice -  hope you enjoy making this recipe have  fun and enjoy oh oh yes  [Music]